there was a big game flood against
Magnus Carlsen how did you win this game
today well I still have to check it with
the computer but it seems to me that it
was a good convincing victory and I
don't know I mean it at least some
points and complications started and it
seems that I was always in control but
ok you know we are just for human so I
want to check just with the city
conference I think one of the critical
moments was taking on left to with the
bishop instead of the Queen yes bishop
asked to finish to Queens III I said but
then rookie 2 with just the best
position I mean he can fight for
sometimes too but I think it's
practically hopeless that's what I
thought
practically speaking Queen takes s2 is a
better decision because it forces white
to find a lot of difficult moves because
yeah I thought Bishop of Cook image -
well I mean beautiful relations Bishop
takes a one Bishop h6 pin to 3/5 and I
made in here it seemed to me so but
Queen c3 is very poor I mean rookie -
that's what Magnus told me after the
game that he just saw that it was pretty
hopeless so he wanted to walk to check
me in complications
by the way was it a difficult choice on
your first move because these days you
are varying a lot on your first move was
difficult and how did you make your
choice yeah I was thinking about playing
some other sorts mafia but finally
decided to stick with before actually
since Magnus was not in good tournament
position I was expecting him to play
something random something sharp so
frankly well exactly this is reporter
which she played I didn't check so
carefully I mean I just remembered my
note I had this Bishop d3 very
interesting idea for white and that was
it I was expecting him to go for
civilian or something like that
so now actually situation is that
theoretically you could be the world
number one tomorrow you're only six
point four six point four point six is
now between you and the life rating list
what does this mean to you no I mean
okay it would be nice of course to
at least for one day you know to be a
hero for one day but it doesn't really
mean much I mean okay
it's not about rating I don't even know
exactly my second now sort I don't know
actually I don't know exactly my rating
now so it's okay I just finished the
torrent I want to play well to finish
the tournament well and then I see what
is the worth of the situation last
question what is your explanation of
Magnus's this morning like well first of
all he's clearly out of form he's
missing some moves for example he told
me to the game that he simply blundered
Bishop take c6 which was really
surprising I mean I was sure that he
went for these complications okay I
think otherwise I'm better but it's
still not so easy but actually he simply
blundered Bishop is mystic so and he
bonded Knight h5 later so he is making
wonders it's clear that he is not in
good form but also I think he's got
certain problems with his black rep
after I mean he was basically almost out
of the opening against Iranian he got
into serious trouble against me so in
this kind of tournament well you need to
be extremely well prepared with black to
avoid problems here so probably he
should work on it and then just to I
don't know to to wait for this bad
period to pass I mean his I believe he's
still the best player in the world and
just meets you know sometimes you have
really bad periods I I myself had a few
in my career and simply you do you know
everything the same but nothing works I
mean everything starts to fall apart but
I think usually you just should keep on
keep on you know working and keep on
waiting and it you know it comes back it
always comes back